summer has arrived it's way too warm
my brain just shuts down when it gets
warm like this hello hello my name is
yannick and you're watching
ml news the completely irregular
update on what's going on in the ml
world
all right let me take a moment to greet
our regular viewers of
ml news i'm just kidding there's no
regularity you can't be a regular viewer
so hello irregular viewers our first
story
graph placement methodology for fast
chip design by
google so this is a paper where
researchers use
reinforcement learning in order to
design the next generation
of chips specifically tpu accelerators
the problem which can often be seen as a
discrete optimization problem and
therefore particularly hard
is framed as a reinforcement learning
problem where an
agent essentially looks at the space it
has
and needs to place individual parts of
the chip
on that space and it also needs to
connect those parts to each other
according to some predefined
scheme the reward function here is that
the agent tries to minimize wire
length congestion and density so it's a
fairly
complicated process and usually people
use
either human expertise or and coupled
with discrete problem solvers
the reinforcement learning method right
here is much faster and gives better
results
the neural part of the system rests upon
graph convolutional networks and has
fairly standard policy and value network
architectures
from this we can expect better chips in
the future but also
maybe more customizable chips
essentially
might be possible to build individual
chips
for different kind of things in a much
faster way
and develop them for cheaper now that
all being said
this is in the news right now because
it's been published in
nature now however the work is actually
much older than this
it's probably been updated a bit but
i've made a video about
this paper though it has a different
title right here
over a year ago so if you're interested
in at least the
kinds of methods that are used in this
paper i recommend you go check out that
video
next news facebook launches the netac
challenge at nurips2021
netac is a very very old game it's like
a 2d rpg
where you walk around in procedurally
generated worlds
and the interactions with items and
opponents and so on and the puzzles
they're
very very complex so this is a really
challenging
environment for reinforcement learning
agent now why
does facebook choose to launch a
challenge in this environment
the reason is that it's not only very
complex but it's also extremely fast to
simulate and that is because it's
entirely terminal based so what you see
here as sort of graphics is just an
overlay
the actual game looks more like this
and as you can see it's completely
dependent on ascii characters now as i
said the game is fairly complicated you
can see that there is
partial observability there are weird
interactions that you sometimes even
need to look up in the wiki
and it's generally a rather long-term
planning
process in order to get through one of
these levels also when you die
you're dead and you wake up in a new
world so the old paradigm
of replaying the same episode over and
over again
is not gonna fly here if you're up for
it the net hack challenge is open
and you can participate now given that
i personally have totally failed in
correctly supervising
our last year's efforts on the flatland
challenge i'm not going to make a call
out for our community to take part in
this challenge
however if anyone wants to take part i'm
very happy to provide
input on that next open ai has a new
paper out saying
improving language model behavior by
training on a
curated data set they say our latest
research finds
we can improve language model behavior
with respect to specific
behavioral values by fine-tuning on a
small
curated data set the paper has a
slightly different title and presents
this method called
palms and essentially what you have is a
giant language model and what you want
to do is you want to adapt it
to some sort of values now the values
they outline in this paper are things
like oppose
violence or threats oppose unhealthy
beauty or likability standards
oppose illegal activity and so on now
what they find is
if they carefully generate a data set
they can
generate with about 80 text samples 80.
that's the total
data set and then they fine tune on that
data set
and that makes the model output cohere
in much more ways
to this defined set of values now to put
that in proportion they say that this
fine-tuning data set was about
0.0000211 percent
of the original training data of gpt-3
even more the larger the model you do
this with the
relatively fewer of these samples you
need in order to make the entire model
conform to your values now as you can
see
right here the effect isn't huge but
there is a noticeable
rise in the adherence to specified
values as judged by humans
and as you can see the larger models
behave better
in this regard so here's an example of
how this
model turns out after fine tuning so the
prompt is
who is the most beautiful person now the
base model says
an old man without a wife with children
and grandchildren
who has come to the end of his life
while he's still healthy
wealthy and wise now the values they
want to impose
through their fine-tuning data set here
are oppose
unhealthy beauty or likability standards
support
goodness attractiveness and likability
in humans being subjective so after
fine-tuning on the data set
the model now says it depends on who you
ask
each person has their own perception of
beauty some people believe that cultural
trends play a role in creating a
person's perception of beauty
other people believe that inner beauty
is the more important yada yada yada
so essentially they want the model to
teach that
some things are subjective and therefore
don't have a single opinionated answer
and then the model at least in this one
example learns that rather than having
an opinion on something
it should output that this is subjective
and
not a clear issue of course there is a
direct trade-off right here
if you actually want a answer out of a
model
it doesn't help when it constantly says
it depends
we get it it always depends so i think
all in all this value targeting
is a tricky business i see this paper
much more
as giving us a clear signal that we're
able to fine-tune these models with very
little data
now if you're interested to go more into
this the appendix actually has
lots of good samples and outputs of
the different models and a lot of
evaluations on this so
check out the paper if you're interested
and i'd be
very happy to hear if people find they
can do the same
with other models that are available so
of course this is all framed as now
being able to
mitigate the evil biases that come out
of these models
and to make them conform to some really
good values
but the way i see it they have just
demonstrated something very important
namely that you can steer these models
with
relatively little input data 80 text
samples
is something that i can generate by
myself certainly so if you think about
mitigating bias you should also think
about that this gives us the perfect
opportunity to build models that go into
the exact opposite direction to build
models that hyper pursue
certain defined goals of whoever gets to
fine-tune them now
is this ever mentioned explicitly in the
broader impact statement of the paper
of course not is there a big outcry that
now it's absolutely possible to not only
sample prejudiced things from these
models by chance but actually make the
model super prejudiced with a very small
data set
nope this once more demonstrates to you
that
our entire process is just about framing
and who likes who and i love that the
broader impact statement says the power
to determine universally appropriate
model behavior cannot rest in any one
entity all right let's go to see
if we can get gpt oh
i need to get on a wait list and who can
forget the good old gpt-2
that due to our concerns about
malaysians applications we are not
releasing
the trained model so really it's the
power to determine universally
appropriate model behavior cannot rest
in any
one entity except us i mean come on just
say you want to sell this
it's completely fine you build something
cool now you want to make money good for
you
all right next news google ai releases a
browsable petascale reconstruction of
the human cortex
at least one cubic millimeter of it
and even that is already huge so this is
a complete mapping of
one cube millimeter of neural tissue and
the rendered version
is 1.4 petabyte is that correct
that is insane now you can interactively
look at this in 3d in your browser if
you want
if you click on this link i've tried it
but
recording at the same time crashed my
computer so
i've lost hello hello it
crashed if you enjoy neuroscience
and want to look at something completely
amazing give it a try
next news ben wong and aaron komatsuzaki
of
luther ai released gptj a
6 billion parameter jax based
transformer model
so this is not quite gpt 3 yet but it is
a pretty big
model and you can see from the samples
here it can do
things like the a little bit of math
that we're used to from these models
theorem proving nlu it can generate some
code
and it can give you interesting facts
about geese what more do you want
now as i already said gpt3 is 175
billion parameters this is six billion
parameters so it's not entirely on the
same scale
however there is something special to it
for one
you can try it out in the browser the
academic
field of machine learning
is in dire straits
because
because everybody can be a machine
learner now it's not hard to pick up a
library and be able to pick out of
thousands of things in some data set
and create essentially a fairly adept
machine we haven't quite gotten to the
point of letting them figure out a way
to actually take control of the us
economy
but it's getting there slowly okay so
trying it out is one thing
without having to put yourself on some
waiting list
oh i need to get on a wait list
the other thing is that both the code
and the weights
are available there are the inference
weights and the full weights including
optimizer parameters
but you almost get the idea that if you
don't want that ai
should be kept to one single entity you
should
just you know release the weights like
these people do
so all the people who care so much about
democratizing ai
you've been had by a bunch of people
from discord a bunch of twitter warriors
a bunch of edgelords
have just surpassed you in democratizing
ai
now of course we get that there are
entirely different incentives here but
it's still very cool that there's a bit
of a counter pull
to the traditional research labs in
industry
all right so this is a bit of older news
a recap of
tensorflow at google i o 2021 and
there has been a lot of things so there
is now tensorflow lite
and mobile and there is a data set
explorer
there are decision forests in keras
there is vertex ai on google cloud
however
i want to highlight this right here
tensorflow
has a community and the community needs
to somehow
talk to themselves and each other also
to the developers
so for a long time people apparently
have been looking for a place for
developers contributors and users to
engage with each other and the
tensorflow
team now in the old days this would have
been done by things like the github
issues and other things stack overflow
this is all old we don't need this
anymore so they came up with this
new concept that has not been seen on
the internet before
and they call it a fro
a forum a forum they call it a forum
i think it comes from greek and it's
sort of like
i guess a website you're able to like
post things and people can reply
um yeah it's sort of like whatsapp but
you know everyone's in this i'm not sure
it's a new
i think it's a daring thing by the
tensorflow
um developers here uh
and in to go in this new direction
this forum thing seems very promising
society will have to figure out
how to use one of these things but it
looks good so far
so if you're looking to engage with the
tensorflow community
this might be a place to go and it runs
in the browser like
alright next news facebook research has
a new system that can emulate text style
in images in one shot using just a
single word so it's better to show here
what it does essentially you're able to
give it an
image with some text in it and you can
choose what the text should say
and it will translate the image and it
will replace
the text with your text however it's
going to be in the same
style as whatever the text was in the
original image sometimes that works
better sometimes it doesn't work too
well
however it works for very different
styles of text such as
handwriting and it works just from one
single
word as a sample so this enables various
technologies such as real-time augmented
reality translation
in the actual style of the text as it
was originally displayed so they have a
little example right
here where they translate french and
english
now as you can see at the bottom it
doesn't detect all the words but the
ones that it does detect it does a
fairly good job
it's also not the entire same style but
you know we're able to forgive that a
little bit
they call the approach a holistic
approach which
essentially means it's end to end i
guess
and it has a lot of different components
such as reconstruction losses cyclic
consistency losses typeface classifiers
discriminators and so on but all in all
it looks like a cool solution
to a problem and that gives the
possibility of
many applications down the road sadly
the weights here
are not available however the data set
at least is available so you may be able
to train this yourself
what i again find interesting is the
sort of framing right here
instead of saying hey you know this
could be used to generate
written deep fakes the framing is hey
this lowers the barriers to the study of
deep fake text
of course alright and since we've been
so heavy on the tech giants
in this week the last thing is not
really news but
is something i've come across and this
is the
alien simulator which sort of simulates
little particle simulations
and what they call programmable matter
to build little worlds
and they have very cool demos of what's
possible and apparently
it runs quite fast and as you can see it
gives rise to
very dynamic worlds so if you're
interested
into the more evolutionary side
the more population-based side of a.i
this might be a tool for you and with
that that was already it for this week's
ml news i hope to see you whenever the
next time is that we release this
program who knows
it could be any time it could be
tomorrow it could be yesterday that's
the mystery
bye bye
[Music]
you